- Hello Believe Nation.
Today I'm going to talk about
seven ways to get 10,000 Youtube views.
♫ Nine, eight
(electronic music)
Alright so Youtube recently came out
with a new policy that
if your channel did not
have at least 10,000
lifetime Youtube views
on your channel
then you would not get any monetization
from Adsense on your channel.
Once you crossed 10,000 views
then you can start making money
and so today I want to share with you
my seven ways on how to
get that first 10,000 views
for your channel.
And for those of you who have
already hit the 10,000 views
these strategies will help you too.
(hiphop beat)
Way number one is make a
video on a trending topic.
Just kind of like what I'm
doing with this video right now.
I'm eating my own dog food.
This is a topic that a lot
of people are talking about.
They're trying to figure out
how do I get my first 10,000 views?
And so what am I doing?
Making a video about
something that's newsworthy
and that people are talking about
to help drive more traffic
and awareness on these videos.
In general, this is not a
strategy that I usually do.
Most of my content is evergreen content.
Meaning, if you watch my
videos from five years ago
it's still relevant, it's still applicable
it's still helpful to you today.
But it's not the strategy
that every Youtuber
needs to go down
or every content creator
needs to go down as well.
So I'd be looking at, is
there anything in the news
that you want to talk about?
Whether it's politics.
Whether it's business.
Whether it's your local economy.
Whatever it is, is there
something newsworthy
that you have an opinion on
that you want to share.
When I was first staring with my agent
he was always coaching me to say
"I want you to take a powerful position
"On this thing that is happening."
This political scene or that
this company did this thing.
And it was really hard for me
because I don't really care.
I don't really have strong opinions
on politics and what else
is happening in the news.
I don't really follow pop
culture, a lot of these things
that people are concerned about.
I don't really care about
most of the newsworthy
buzzworthy things.
And so I couldn't create content around it
but it doesn't mean that you can't.
And it's a powerful way to help you get
your first 10,000 views.
(hiphop beat)
Way number two is to
create a reaction video.
If you look at a video
that is already having
a lot of success
it's easy to piggyback off of that video
by making a similar one
with your own thoughts, your own opinions.
So for example, if a
channel put out a video
about the top seven marketing
books for entrepreneurs.
If you had a thought on that
you want to share your list
of books for entrepreneurs
you can make a video with the same topic.
The top seven books for
entrepreneurs in marketing.
And then you can share
your thoughts right?
It's not just copying
what somebody else did
from the topic point of view
but adding more context and clarity
around your opinions of it.
So the goal is, when
somebody watches that video
yours is going to be the next
one that pops up right afterwards
so if you use a similar title
you use some of the same
words in the description
you use similar tags
then you're likely to show up
after that first video.
Just make sure again,
that you're adding value
you're adding some context there
or you're adding something
that's worth watching.
You have something that you want to add
your own opinion to
and you're not just trying to piggyback
off of somebody for the wrong reasons.
There has to still be a good quality video
but if you can create
a good reaction video
or a good piggyback video
then it's much easier to
get those initial views
coming into your channel.
(hiphop beat)
Way number three is update
your social media bios.
In most social media platforms
you have an opportunity to put a link.
Where is that link going?
What you want to do
is try to get as much
traffic and much attention
going to your Youtube channel as possible.
You want to hit that 10,000 views
as quickly as possible.
And so there's actually a cool tool
out of TubeBuddy.
TubeBuddy is a tool that I use.
I don't know if this is part
of the free version or not.
I'm not associated with the company
apart from being a happy user.
They have an option to have a link
to your most recent Youtube video.
And so right now, that's the
bio for my Twitter account.
It's the bio for my Instagram account.
It's the bio on my Facebook account.
I don't think it's Linkedin.
I've got to update my Linkedin account.
So anytime somebody goes
to see my social media
they see that link, they can click on it.
It will take them to my most recent video.
Even if you don't do that
you can link them to a single video
that you really want to promote
or you can lead them to your channel
that you really want to promote.
Having that link, because most
of the time you get one link.
Put it in there so that any time
somebody checks you on social media
they're also going to check
out your Youtube videos.
As a side note, you can
also put it in your emails.
At the bottom of my
emails in every signature
it will say, "Here's a
link to my latest video."
So that anytime you send
an email out to somebody
you put it as a PS, just
have it as a default
in your signature.
You send out emails, people like it.
Some are going to click through
and you get more views on your channel.
(hiphop beat)
Number four is do some collabs.
One of the best ways to grow a channel
is to partner up and
collaborate with somebody
who already has an audience
and channel of their own.
It doesn't have to be a massive channel.
But they have a similar sized channel
or maybe slightly bigger than yours
and you're giving them value
that they can promote to their audience.
You have a video on their channel now.
People are going to learn about you.
They're going to want to
say, "Hey who is that person?
"What's their channel?
"Let me check them out."
And they're going to funnel your way.
Some of the first collabs I did
was with Youtubers Tim Schmoyer
and Derral Eves.
I've done four collabs
with stand alone videos
I think with Tim.
I was part of his Youtube
entrepreneur series
that ran for 12 episodes.
Derral I think we did one video together.
And it was just basically finding ways
that I could add value to their audience
at the time they both had bigger audiences
than I did.
And so it really helped me
get some initial traffic
and views on my channel.
I've gone on to do a
lot more collaborations.
We've had guests come on my channel.
I've been on other people's channels.
I did a series with Brian Tracy
the sales and time management expert
where we did the top 10
rules for entrepreneurs.
Something like that, he
had five on his channel.
I had five on my channel.
At the end of our videos, we both said
go check out the other person's channel
to see the other five rules.
So those kinds of things.
Coming up with creative
ways to market yourself
and work with other Youtube creators
ideally somewhat in the same space
so they have an audience that
is related to your audience.
It's kind of the same base from.
That they would want
to then check you out.
If I look at Tim's
audience, Derral's audience
as an example
their audiences are all Youtubers.
People who only want to build an income
based off of Youtube.
But they're all entrepreneurs
so it's a subsegment
of my audience as well
and so those collaborations
really did some work.
So look at who is already in your market.
Who is doing videos for an audience
that is similar to yours
and how can you find
a way to work together
and give them value?
(hiphop beat)
Way number five is make a one word video.
Now you may know what your one word is.
You may know what you're all about.
You may understand what your
you know, core value is.
You may not know, and you
can check out the book
if you want to.
Even if you can't get it down to one word
just understanding why you're here.
It's making a why video.
What is this channel all about?
Why is it so important?
And not just, not from
a mental point of view.
Not from a here's why you need
to subscribe to my channel.
Nobody really cares about those videos.
But from the heart.
Something coming out that you have made
that you just think is awesome.
The video that helped explode my channel
the first video that really took off
and got 100,000 views in the first month
and now it's at two million views
was Believe, it was a video about believe.
When I watched it, it was like yes.
That's what it's about.
That's what I want people to feel
when they come and visit my channel.
That's what I want
entrepreneurs to look at
on a regular basis and feel every day
as they bring that to their business.
So, a passionate why video
for what you're doing here.
Why is this so important to you.
Something that when you watch it
it gets your blood excited
and say yes, that's it.
That's the feeling I want people to feel.
If you can pour that
kind of love and energy
into making that kind of heroic video.
Then you have a good chance
of getting those first 10K views.
(hiphop beat)
Way number six is get
your friends to help.
You have friends, let them
know about your channel
and let them know about your mission.
Let them know what you're trying to do.
Let them know you're
trying to get to 10K views.
Send them the videos
that you feel are most relevant to them.
That they would enjoy
they find some value at,
that they may want to share
and help other people with as well.
I still use this strategy.
As an example, when I was
trying to get interviews
for your one word.
I interviewed the Honest Company.
And to get in the door
I made a video on it
and then I asked people to leave comments
on the video
to show that there was
engagement and action
and then I could take
that to the Honest Company
and say, "Hey look, people are curious.
"People want to hear from you.
"How about we set up a meeting
"So that I can have you in my book?"
And so where I got the
most results from that
was actually my Facebook friends.
I sent it to my Youtube audience.
I sent out a couple of
newsletters to my newsletter list
and said, "Hey guys, can
you support me in this?
"Here's what I'm trying to do.
"Can you please leave a
comment on this video?"
But I got the best results
from my Facebook friends.
Where I went down my entire list
and I had a message and it said
"Dear whoever, I'm trying to do this.
"Can you please support me?
"Watch this video, leave a comment on it.
"It would really, really,
really mean a lot to me."
That was the highest response rate
and it lead to the most number of comments
on that video.
And so I wouldn't
underestimate your friends.
I would look at the people
who you hang out with.
It doesn't have to be your close friends.
But friends of friends.
People who you know, they
would recognize your name
if you went off and
asked them for a favor.
And sharing the mission, sharing the why.
Saying like, I'm trying to get
my channel to 10,000 views.
It would really help me
start monetizing my channel
and it's really super
helpful and important to me.
Or this is one video
that you're really trying
to get the attention of somebody with
and your support of commenting or sharing
would really, really help me.
If it feels like a heartfelt message.
People want to support
other people's dreams.
And especially if it's only a view.
It's only a comment and you're not asking
for somebody to give you money for it.
Then it can really help get that channel
to where you want it to go.
So get your friends
involved and ask for help.
(hiphop beat)
And way number seven to get
10,000 views on your channel
is to make a listicle video.
People like listicle videos.
What's a listicle video? This!
I'm eating my own dog food again.
Right, seven ways to do something.
Whatever idea you have,
whatever your message is.
Whatever level of expertise you have.
You can make a top 10
list, a top seven list
a top eight ways, a top nine secrets.
Making a listicle video
helps make it easy for people to digest
and when people see numbers in a video
they're much more likely to click through
for whatever reason.
So try to take that
expertise that you have
those opinions that you have
and form it in a list
and make that video.
It's much more likely to
stand out and succeed.
So those are my seven
ways to get your first
10,000 views on your channel.
I'd love to know what did you think?
What strategy is your favorite
that you're going to now immediately apply
on your channel?
Do you have an eight, nine,
10 that you want to add
to that list as well?
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm super curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick shout out
to Charles Botensten.
Charles, thank you so
much for picking up a copy
of my book, Your One Word
and the fun video that you put together
on your channel.
I really, really
appreciate the support man
and I'm glad you enjoyed the book.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.